there hasn't been a single republican  administration in any of our lifetimes  that's actually added more jobs or  performed better than a democratic  administration in fact most of the  republican administrations are  plunging us deep into recessions and  then the democratic presidents have to  get us out of those recessions and if  you can point to a single example in the  last three decades of that not being the  case i'd love to hear it well let's ryan  biden sent us into a recession right now  we officially entered into a recession  last week and when you keep citing the  unemployment numbers the government  forced the economy to shut down for two  years so yes of course when you tell  people they're allowed to go back to  work they will go back to work that's  not the sign of economic health